so hello everyone at home and welcome to
another episode of biographics I'm your
interim host Carl small and today we're
talking about Marvin hea architect of
the kild Dozer before we get to the meat
and potatoes of today's video which is
the awesomely named kildo band name
calling it like give a shout out to the
author of this piece Ben Adelman who you
can follow at the social media links
below while you're down there why not
give the channel a follow a like and
comment with some feedback suggestions
um for future videos so I've been asked
to say because Analytics show that me
asking people to do those three things
means they're more likely to happen
which means we make more money and can
keep making more videos and I can just
sit in my house drinking coffee talking
about a guy who built a giant
bulletproof bulldozer and Rampage
through a town which is
awesome on the morning of June 4th 2004
Granby Colorado was no different from
hundreds of other small towns all across
the United States it was a kind of idic
little mountain town you move to in
order to get away from the crime and
Chaos of big cities like the neighboring
Denver by the end of the day on June 4th
gramby looked like it been through a war
zone with buildings destroyed trees
ripped up street lights and fire
hydrants knocked over you might be
forgiven for thinking the cause this
Municipal damage was some sort of
natural disaster but the truth was so
much more bizarre a bulldozer modified
with armor plating to make it impervious
to gunfire and indeed virtually all
forms of conventional damage has spent
the afternoon driving around
deliberately crashing into things the
man that controls the machine nicknamed
the kild Dozer again band name calling
it was well known to the town's people
of gambi Marvin HEI was one of their
neighbors a local business owner who had
lots of friends was also Infamous for
his well publicized disputes with the
local town government few people had
recognized the simmering anger beneath
hea's skin he had apparently been
holding on to for years until he finally
emerged with a suicidal plan to get
revenge on anyone he felt had ever
wronged him many people even his own
victims were left in awe at the sheer
Audacity Of His attack including the
time effort and resources that went into
building such an infernal Contraption in
the first place Marvin has been held up
as a hero in the years since his Rampage
by many particularly among
anti-government tipes who view me as a
good person who finally snapped after
being pushed too far by the man the
truth however is far more sad that heah
was a successful man who became consumed
with perceived slice and Petty
grievances made against him until he
became so consumed with rage that he
threw away everything he'd ever worked
for in a rampage that was just as much
about self-destruction as it was about
well the regular kind of Destruction but
we're getting ahead of ourselves we
should start as we often do at the
beginning Marvin John HEI decided soon
after he was born in 1951 that he wasn't
qu out for life on a South Dakota farm
like many Farm boys go out by joining
the military in he's case the Air Force
where he mostly worked as a clerk though
his tour of Duty would taking to Exotic
locals like West Germany what really
stuck with him was a stint at Lowry Air
Force Base in Denver Colorado he fell in
love with the mountains decided to make
his home there after being discharged
while admittedly not great at what you
would call that fancy book learning
stuff hea was good at working with his
hands able to pick up most trades fairly
quickly in particular welding after
working at a couple of muffler repair
shops in the Denver area he decided to
go into business for himself and by all
accounts he was quite successful so
successful that by 1989 he was able to
to retire to the mountain town of Grand
Lake a 100 mile drive to the northwest
of Denver in order to get to Grand Lake
which sits on the western edge of the
Rocky Mountain National Park you have to
drive on US Route 40 through the town of
gambi gramby is the largest town in
Grand County though with a population of
2,000 that isn't really saying much it
is typical of most small Crossroads
towns that dot the Rocky Mountains most
people pass through gramby on their way
to somewhere else in particular the
National Park to the northeast or the hu
ski resorts and Winter Park to the South
or Steamboat Springs in the Northwest
it's not easy living in the mountains
with its long frigid Winters and short
cool Summers many gramby residents can
trace their history back to the first
settlers in the area in the 1860s but it
does also attract its fair share of
newcomers too people who like the
outdoors people who find City Life
stifling and want to get away from it
all or those who can't quite fit in with
the people around them people like
Marvin
heaya hea first came to the attention of
citizens of gramb B in 1992 when he
purchased a 2 acre business property
being sold at auction along with other
assets of the failed Middle Park Bank
initially intending to lease the
property to a friend he eventually
decided to just keep it for himself and
open up a muffler repair business just
like with his Early Adventures this
business was quite successful in no
small part because hea known to his
friends as marf was considered to be an
exceptional welder marf was somewhat
less skilled however navigating the
municipal authorities that govern the
town of gambi his first running came
soon after purchasing the property
regarding the seie system or rather the
lack of a seie system the property's
toilets were flushed directly into an
old concrete mixing bowl buried in the
ground considered neither legal nor
altogether sanitary heaya wanted to
connect to the town sewer lines well
that would require the installation of
100 ft of sewage pipe as well as a lift
station pump since the sewage would need
to be pumped upwards to connect to the
line and for anyone curious about the
cost of such a project it was reported
that it would have cost anywhere between
50 and $775,000
and that Marvin would have had to absorb
all of the cost he refused claiming that
the town should pay for it which the
town thought was absurd it's his
property and their sewage line after all
perhaps in an attempt at diplomacy Town
official did know that hea could just
install a septic tank on the property
which would be cheaper but he refused to
do that too eventually the town decided
to just leave the issue alone hoping it
would sort itself out because eventually
HEI would have to do something about the
poop right in the mean time another
issue came along that terms normally
boring meetings at gramby Town Hall into
hotly contested Affairs so in 1997 a
gramby businessman named Cody doef
announced plans to build a concrete
production plant on the lot adjacent to
hea's business hea was publicly opposed
to this project and did successfully
manage to Rally many other neighbors who
objected to the noise dust and heavy
commercial traffic that would naturally
come along with the building of a
concrete plant the debate dragged on for
years culminating in hea suing both do
chef and the town itself claiming that
the proposed plan would harm his
business in spite of the fact that
several alterations have been made to
satisfy his many initial concerns people
who have been initially allied with
heier did turn against him when it came
out that prior to submitting their
proposal doef had attempted to purchase
he's property only to have M continually
rebuff and then raise the price from
$250,000 then to
$375,000 and finally to
$450,000 when doef rejected what he
thought was an exorian price for such a
property heah then announced that he'd
campaign against the plant hea's former
allies start thinking that Mar was
motivated more by personal Vendetta and
monetary gain than any real legitimate
concern about its effects on the town
the concrete plant was eventually
approved by the town Committee in 2000
with ow Marvin objecting to its
construction he's lawsuit was eventually
dismissed by a municipal judge put him
on the hook for more than $50,000 in
court costs and attorney's fees at the
same time his sewer problems at his
business weren't going away as poop is
want to do when you don't have sewage
pipe to flush it down after his
neighbors complained that MV was just
dumping his sewage into an irrigation
ditch that they owned which was not
great gramb municipal authorities
finally told Marvin that he needed to
get a proper Waste Disposal system
installed or he would be fine you know
for for all the poop He was dumping this
was easily done because the do chefs had
actually offered him a free easement to
hook on to the sewer system that they
were installing at their concrete plant
if he agreed to drop his lawsuit but
Marvin refused almost daring gramby to
find him which they eventually did by
this point hear have become convinced
that the entire town of grammy was being
run by a good old boys network that was
working together in conspiracy to
destroy his business and while sitting
in his hot tub one day in January 2001
heaya said he had a revelation from God
that he needed to get revenge on
everyone that had screwed him over in
gry and he had an idea on just how he
was going to do it dun dun dun killed
there was a time no it's not he's got
build it first by the summit of 2002
after his lawsuits had been dismissed
and he was battling down over the sewage
system heia closed down his business
announcing he was going to auction off
all his equipment and leave town but
while he was doing this he also traveled
to an equipment auction in California
and paid some $116,000 for a huge 60 son
bulldozer made by the Japanese company
kamasi Marv moved the bulldozer into a
large steel shed concealing what he was
doing from the world he installed
security cameras around the shed so that
you could see what was happening outside
eventually moved into the shed fulltime
sleeping on a Cott and going to the
bathroom in a bucket so that he could
spend more time working on the bulldozer
if only he had a working sewage system
which slowly but surely over the course
of 18 months was transforming into a
tank a kill Dozer if you
will
now Marvin heah didn't exactly fit the
stereotypical profile of the Lone Wolf
rampager he had lots of friends in both
Grand Lake and gramby particularly the
crew that he went snowmobile riding with
up in the mountains at least once a week
in spite of how much he claimed he was
being destroyed by gramby and his
residence he actually came out ahead
when he started selling his property to
a trash company for 10 times what he
paid for it a decade before sure he
wasn't married and he didn't have kids
but by all accounts he had many
girlfriends his friends claimed that
there was nothing he wouldn't do to help
you if you needed it they had a hard
time understanding why he end up doing
what he did and formed the core of his
Defenders after June 4th 2004 but there
was a another sight of M that his
friends weren't familiar with but his
business associates absolutely were
their statements real a man who was
deeply distrustful other people when it
came to money he was almost always
convinced that anyone he did business
with was out to cheat him and was prone
to overreacting even to the point of
trying to cheat them first he even
resorts to threatening people he's
involved in business disputes with to
bully them into pay up though he had no
Runnings with the law on his record when
he was you know kill ozer in it all up
it appeared that heah took really any
perceived slight or insult against him
whether it actually happened or not and
internalized it allowing rage to build
up inside of him like a pot filled with
boiling water and at some point he
allowed it to drive his actions until
the only thing that mattered to him was
getting an outlet for his anger by
getting back at his enemies yeah so
there's been a lot of speculation about
hea's mental state prior to his Rampage
but this stewing in Rage and grievance
lines up with the minds of many other
men who've committed Rampage style
crimes including those who bring guns to
the workplace and murder their
co-workers and also like many other
rampagers he have seem to realize in the
weeks prior to June 4th that his mission
for lack of a better term was a suicidal
one he systematically gave away almost
all of his wealth and possessions to
family and friends including his
home at 2: p.m. on June 4th 2004 Mar hea
crashed through the wall of the shed at
the control of his bulldozer which now
looked like something out of a science
fiction movie Allah Mad Max his first
Port of Call was Cody df's concrete plan
and he began destroying it crashing into
walls and pillars before backing out and
moving on to another section to crash
into it again plant workers fled for
their lives and the building began to
collapse some barely escaping in time
speaking of kind of cool that some of
the workers led by do himself actually
attempted to disable the balos by
jamming steel bars into the gears of the
Treads it didn't work but it looked
awesome then GF decided to just fire
upon the machine with a pistol the first
of more than 200 rounds would be
expended that day and again this had no
effects but just the image of a guy
defending his business from a
bulletproof like 85 ton bulldozer by
hitting it with a stick and then
shooting a gun at it is too rad and if I
was that guy I would have made that just
when I reopen that concrete plant that
would just be the image outside I'd have
just a picture this is how much I care
about my business like pew pew pew
take that kild Dozer but yeah as
mentioned the bullets had no effect and
nobody knew it at the time but he might
had spent a year and a half
systematically welding two layers of
half inch thick steel plates all over
the driver's cab and the engine
compartment he then filled the 4-in gap
between the plates with concrete making
the machine which afterwards would earn
the admittedly awesome moniker of the
kildo almost impervious to all outside
attack and for anyone thinking well
surely this thing had a weak point right
what about Windows well it didn't have
Windows either because Mar had similarly
block those up and instead rigged up
five video cameras to the outside of the
bulldozzer which you might think okay so
they're a weak point right you can get
the cameras and he's blind but no he
thought about that and covered the
covers to the cameras in bulletproof
plexiglass so he could see where he was
going and nobody could stop him from
doing so like doef even tried to Ram
into the bulldozzer with a front and
loader and only succeeded in knocking
himself unconscious in the process but
while the kild Dozer just continued on
its merry way police officers began to
arrive on the scene pretty shortly there
after because reports of a giant
bulldozer destroying everything tends to
attract police attention and this
included Grand County's Sheriff deputies
and the Colorado State patrolman but
none of them could figure out how to
stop the bulldozer either under Sheriff
Glenn trainer who took command of the
scene initially thought that the machine
might have been radio controlled at
least until it started shooting at him
and his officers he might as it turned
out have built three gun parts into the
front back and side of his creation and
periodically would stop moving to just
fire pot shots at the cops attempting to
stop him his deadliest weapon besides
the kild Dozer itself though was a
Barrett M82 50 caliber sniper rifle that
cost hea some
$7,000 and anyone who's played Call of
Duty knows what this thing can do but
for out those was unfamiliar with the uh
the capability of the Barrett 50 caliber
sniper rifle it's usually referred to as
a antimaterial rifle and it's normally
used to attack things like armored
personnel carriers or soldiers who are
hiding inside of bunkers having
thoroughly destroyed the concrete plant
the bulldo then headed Southeast into
grany proper next attacking the officers
of Mountain Park's Electrical Company
then the Maple Street Builders all while
police officers followed along trying
desperately to figure out a way to stop
the Rampage before somebody got hurt or
Worse killed it was quickly decided to
take advantage of the reverse 911 system
to notify every resident of gramy to
evacuate their homes with special
attention paid to anyone who'd ever had
past Runnings with Marvin haer who by
this point was already suspected as
being the
driver under Sheriff trainer had climbed
onto the top of the armor plate of
bulldozer by this point firing his hand
gun down into what looked like an
exhaust port to no effect after noticing
that his attacks were having no effect
trainer jumped off the kildo as he drove
his homemade tank towards gramby town
hall where most of the contentious
meetings between HEI and the town board
had taken place it was also home to the
town's Library where several children
were waiting the start of Story Hour
Library workers did manage to evacuate
the children just in time and the entire
building was demolished including heavy
damage to the library by now
understandably the Rampage was
attracting attention from outside of
gambi news helicopters from Denver
arrived on the scene and film the
destruction in real time and much of
this news footage does exist online and
you can follow pretty much the entirety
of the thing in YouTube videos and the
police helicopters at the time were
having a lot of trouble trying to follow
the action themselves cuz that's keep
jockeying for space with news
helicopters who understandably didn't
want to not film this because it's kind
of a story that people want to follow
but still something needs to be done to
stop this thing so on the topic of
stopping the kildo of the police who
possess no weapons capable of even
breaching the bulldozer defenses asked
for the Colorado National Guard to be
called in and why you might think track
call in the National Guard would have
been the first Port of Call it was
something that had to go through
official channels in this case the
governor Bill Owens who would later
report that he seriously considered
calling in an Apache attack helicopter
armed with anti-tank missiles to take
out the kilder but was persuaded not to
when he realized that shooting anti-tank
missiles into a small town might cause
civilian casualties so all while this
was happening heaya ran the bulldozzer
into several more buildings some
Vehicles some trees a few light fixtures
Liberty Savings Bank and Sky High news
both sustained heavy damage in the
process heire then went after one of the
chief targets of his rage the Thompson
family who owned an excavation company
in town and whose Patriot Ron had once
served as gamby's mayor the kildo did
Heavy damage to several Thompson
properties including the home of Ron's
82 year old Widow Thelma who was
fortunately evacuated prior to the
arrival of the kildo Marv then drove
into a storage yard of independent
propane which had an estimated
75,000 gallons of liquid propane stored
in huge tanks HEI then decided to
significantly up the stakes by shooting
at the tanks with his 50 caliber rifle
using incendiary rounds which he was
apparently allowed to have to try and
puncture and ignite the propane which
would have resulted in a massive
explosion that experts would later
conclude would have vaporized everyone
within a thousand yard radius including
the occupants of a senior citizen home
that police were scrambling to evacuate
fortunately for the people in that
senior citizen's home HEI had over
engineered the machine and the Scraper
on the back could not be load enough to
give the rifle a clear Field of Fire and
ended up shooting at his own armor
instead of the propane
tank
after traversing pretty much the entire
length of gramby the kildo now left the
propane farm and headed west back to
town during this time two huge scrapers
operated by Grand County had done battle
with the kildo are trying to stop it to
no avail the armor plating added an
additional 25 tons of bulk to the
machine giving it a total weight of some
85 tons which was more than enough
weight and power to Simply push the
scrapers aside back in town HEI bulldo
Gamble's General storm completely
flattening it but this is where Mar's Lu
ran out because the right tread got
stuck in a basement in the rear of
gambles that he didn't know about and he
was unable to free it at the same time
kolan had burst out of a hose in the
engine compartment a sign the block was
reaching the point of overheating and
even if he got out of the basement he
couldn't operate for much longer anyway
and after 2 hours of Destruction MV shut
the engine off at this point SWAT teams
swarmed around the machine trying to
find a way any way inside when a pop was
heard from inside none of them knew it
at the time but it was over HEI had shot
himself in the head with a handgun it
took hours for the police to figure out
a way to even get inside the kildo three
explosive charges failed to even Dent
the armor plating so a cutting torch was
used to slice a hole in the steel casing
and everyone moved with caution due to
the very real fear that the machine had
been rigged to explode or had booby
traps built into its armor plating
fortunately there were none either early
the next morning they finally breached
the bulldozer cab and discovered M hea's
lifeless body and many rampagers commit
that wearing You Know M ninja tier
tactical gear or dressed all in black to
you know try and intimidate and scare
people but Marvin had gone to battle for
the final time wearing a brightly
colored Hawaiian shirt it was just one
more absurdity to add on top of an
already very strange day and it's been
so hard not to
take miraculously Marvin HEI and was the
only casualty of the events of June 4th
2004 nobody else was killed or even
seriously injured though there were some
close calls you know the people who
jumped on top of it to try and stop it
for example the property damage on the
other hand was enormous seven businesses
were either totally destroyed or heavily
damaged to the point they had to be you
know flattened and rebuilt this is
alongside the town hall building a few
private residences some street lights
fire hydrant trees several vehicles and
the town's playground equipment the guy
he attacked the playground what a and
the total cost to public and private
property after all was said and done was
estimated to total in at some $1 million
gramby Colorado found itself at the
center of the nation's media coverage
for about 24 hours you thinking well
this sounds like a big deal why wasn't
it not covered for longer than 24 hours
and that's because the very next day
former president Ronald Reagan died and
the bulldozer Rampage almost completely
disappeared off the front page gambi
meanwhile attempts to move on from the
destruction they built a new town hall a
new library while the private businesses
affected had varying levels of
difficulty getting open back up
depending on insurance payout as for
what happened to M HEI his body was
taken cremated and his ashes were
scattered by his friends or the
mountains as part of the snowmobile ride
the kind had enjoyed prior to his
Rampage as for the kildo well that was
kept mostly intact for about a year
while the debate raged on about what to
actually do with it and there were some
proposals which range from the comedic
to the completely sincere to the
establishing of an annual Dozer day in
to commemorate the event and attract
tourist keeping the machine as kind of a
monument to the whole thing which just
okay no one died but it seems in poor
taste to like lionize a guy who tried to
commit an act of mass murder on an
entire town and thankfully cool and more
sensible heads prevailed and the Machine
was scrapped and the piece is sent to
various scrapyards to discourage
souvenir hunting by weirdos who collect
memorabilia for potential Mass murderers
in the Years following hea's Rampage he
has become kind of a cult hero in
certain communities on the internet you
know the one that people don't like to
talk about or go to these fans mainly
anti-government tits completely believe
Marv's story about there being a small
town conspiracy to destroy him despite
virtually all evidence to the contrary
they even embellish upon the story he
himself would tell claiming that the
concrete plant block road access to he's
business or at the Town deliberately
disconnected him from the sewer line and
then finded him for it both of which are
demonstrably false the point it appears
is to betray Marvin heah as a good man
who was simply pushed too far by a
corrupt government so I had no choice to
do what he did they point to the fact
there were no other fatalities that day
other than his own as evidence that he
didn't really want to hurt anyone even
though realistically there was no way
for him to know whether or not the
buildings he was crashing into in his 85
ton purpose built kildo had people in
them also the whole taking pot shots at
propane tanks with incendiary rounds
from a giant sniper rifle thing um kind
of you know all over that theory at best
he might simply didn't care if he killed
any one during his Rampage or at worst
he was actively trying to take as many
people with him as he could others
though are simply amazed at the level of
dedication and craftsmanship it took to
build the kildo in the first place which
admittedly it's pretty impressive that
just a random dude built something that
the combined might of like you know an
entire police force and with backup from
all manner of extra um Services couldn't
even stop let alone admittedly it is
kind of impressive that one dude with a
couple thousand dollars and some knoow
managed to build something that was for
all intents and purposes completely
Unstoppable and even among he's intended
victims few people can find it within
themselves to hate him mostly they just
feel sorry for him and it's not hard as
easy as it is to make fun of him as some
kind of weirdo crackpot which I'm
absolutely doing right now the story of
Mimi is ultimately a very sad one it's a
man who had what most people think of as
a pretty good life yet he still couldn't
figure out a way to be happy with what
he had instead he became so consumed
with what he believed other people owed
him what he thought they done to him
that he went completely over the edge
and an entire town suffered as a
result and I hope everybody watching at
home found this video informative
entertaining and educational I certainly
found the script to be all three of
those things the script as mentioned was
written by Ben Adelman follow them and
myself on social media at the links
below and also while you're down there
why not like the video leave some
comments with feedback or suggestions
other things we could cover subscribe
for more videos like this and as I
always like to say go out there and have
the day you all
deserve